cult emergency on his hands than a
national emergency the borders at coote
surrey windsor and emerson have all been
cleared there are no more blockades at
any borders trucks are still here
downtown in ottawa and they need to move
but in light of the rapidly changing
landscape can the prime minister tell us
where is the serious threat of violence
to canadians for ideological purposes
which is the threshold that needs to be
met for the emergencies act
[Applause]
mr speaker the invocation of the
emergencies act is not something to be
done lightly it is not something to done
as a first resort or even a second
resort but it was necessary to be done
to give local law enforcement across the
country the tools to handle these
illegal blockades uh to be able to
ensure
restoration of order to make sure that
canadians whether they're losing shifts
or seeing supplies delayed on the way
through the borders be able to get back
uh to their daily lives this is a
decision we took and of course uh
parliament is going to have an
opportunity to debate it
the leader of the
opposition the law is clear
any limitations to canadians fundamental
freedoms must be justified and must meet
a legal criteria experts across the
country have said these requirements
have not been met the prime minister
hasn't given canadians a clear reason
why he's invoking the emergencies act in
fact things are de-escalating as we
speak
so why is the prime minister using this
hammer on canadians
isn't it true he's doing it just to save
his own political skin
the right honorable prime minister
mr speaker over the past few weeks
canadians have been suffering whether
it's
because of border crossings
whether it's because of illegal
blockades in their neighborhoods
this is something that required extra
tools that we have put in law
enforcement's hands now of course law
enforcement local law enforcement
jurisdiction can use these tools or not
as they are available but the threshold
was met for the emergencies act and now
across the country police of
jurisdiction have the tools necessary to
keep people safe
the honorable leader of the opposition
the prime minister calls people he
disagrees with racist misogynists he
spent the last month wedging dividing
stigmatizing and traumatizing canadians
i understand the prime minister admires
basic dictatorships but let's remind the
prime minister this is canada this is
not a dictatorship
is actually pouring gasoline on embers
isn't it true the prime minister is
doing this for one reason and one reason
alone it's to save his own political
career
[Applause]
simply can't have it both ways they
spent weeks complaining that we weren't
doing enough uh to restore order in this
country and now when we move forward to
give people the tools they need i'm
going to have to interrupt the honorable
prime minister prime minister
uh you know i've been getting
emails from people who are watching us
at home and they're pretty ashamed of
their parliament because of the shouting
that goes on one person brought
something up
they said well all the shouting happens
at the beginning why not start with the
end questions
if this continues at the beginning i'm
going to the last question turn my list
upside down and we'll start at the end
the honorable prime minister please
continue
mr speaker conservatives can't have it
both ways they spent the first few weeks
of this uh challenge and illegal
blockades saying that the government
needed to act and take responsibility
and then when we finally move forward in
a responsible way when the time was
right to bring in the emergencies act
they are now complaining uh that we've
done too much at the same time and
throughout mr speaker they continue to
stand with and support and cheer on
these illegal blockades mr speaker
they're the ones playing politics
the honourable leader of the opposition
the man who wore black face more times
than he can remember took a terrorist
with him to a trip for on india
gave omar khadar 10 million dollars
we're not going to stop talking to our
constituents just because the prime
minister disagrees with
[Applause]
says he's him science when it comes to
mandates but that's not what canada's
top doctors are saying it's time to end
the mandates and the restrictions the
prime minister is ignoring the science
there is a mental health crisis in this
country and continued lockdowns and
mandates keeping canadians separated are
making it worse so will the prime
minister commit to canadians he'll
follow the sign full prime minister
mr speaker the invocation of the
emergencies act is something that is
extremely serious and that we have taken
extremely seriously
it followed specific steps that were
taken that will continue in this house
it followed consultation with the
premiers and it gives the tools in a
proportionate and responsible way uh to
the officers of jurisdiction to be able
to end these illegal blockades uh this
will be a moment that will be studied in
the history books and what the people
will see was the conservatives never
stop playing personal partisan politics
let's try the honourable member for
kitchener center i believe he has a
question today
[Applause]
mr speaker
there is no doubt the pandemic has had a
devastating impact on our mental health
putting further strain on a system that
already had long-standing gaps in
waterloo wellington 15 children and
youth were waiting to be seen by child
psychiatrists at cmha before the
pandemic now they have 190 on the a
waiting list the fact is mental health
is health
as called for by the canadian alliance
on mental health and mental illness and
others will the prime minister
prioritize funding and legislation to
ensure every canadian has timely access
to inclusive and accessible mental
health
right honorable prime minister mr
speaker i can't agree enough with the
member for kitchener center mental
health is health we must ensure it is a
full and equal part of our universal
health care system it's why we're
committing to establishing the canada
mental health transfer to expand the
delivery of high quality free mental
health services we want to encourage all
canadians who need support to check out
wellnesstogether.ca
for resources and download the
pocketwell app available 24 7 where you
can access a range of resources
including free and confidential virtual
sessions with social workers
psychologists and other professionals
the honorable leader of the opposition
mr speaker the numbers speak for
themselves alcohol and substance abuse
suicide domestic violence and child
abuse have all increased over the last
two years these are not just statistics
these are real canadians who are dealing
with real heartache and unnecessary
mandates and restrictions are hurting us
all
science has saved lives and the science
is clear we can start to open up mr
speaker will the prime minister trust
the numbers trust the experts and tell
us when he'll end the mandates and the
restrictions
honorable prime minister
do you know how difficult these past two
years have been for canadians with this
pandemic but we also have demonstrated
that throughout it canadians have each
other's backs just like this government
has had canadians backs with vaccines
with rapid tests with supports for small
businesses workers and families we will
continue to have people's backs and
follow the science that's why we were
pleased uh to announce loosening of the
restrictions on border on borders as
travel is more available to canadians
and we will continue to follow the the
science every step of the way to keep
canadians
is
[Applause]
[Music]
on
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
foreign
is
[Applause]
mr speaker we are in a national crisis
because all levels of government
have failed to acknowledge the
seriousness of this crisis
on top of that we see
a glaring difference in the treatment of
indigenous
and racialized protesters as composed
the way as opposed to the way that
convoy is being treated canadians are
deeply concerned about that so what is
the prime minister going to do to
address the serious concerns that people
have that there is a disproportionate
treatment of racialized people and
indigenous people as compared to the
convoy and what will he do to fix that
the right honorable prime minister mr
speaker as a government for a number of
years now we've recognized systemic
racism and pledged and worked towards
reducing it uh the reality that
racialized canadians indigenous
canadians face uh worst outcomes and
treatments uh from uh the our justice
system from uh police systems is one of
those things that we have pledged to
counter we work closely with black and
indigenous communities to make sure that
we are reducing the barriers and
ensuring equitable treatment
particularly in moments of crisis like
this one
burnaby south
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
where it's not needed
is
is
between the 11th and 14th of february to
justify these decisions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
is
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
the emergency measures act is a
declaration of a state of national
urgency it is a blunt force tool that
should only be used under the most
serious circumstances when legal powers
have been exhausted
canadians do not believe that this prime
minister has exhausted all efforts the
emergency measures act gives
extraordinary powers to the government
the prime minister would have received
judicial advice from judicial officers
when will this prime minister make that
advice available to the public
[Applause]
sorry once again the conservative party
is trying to have it both ways uh they
spent the first few weeks both uh
complaining that the federal government
wasn't acting while encouraging the
illegal barricades and now that the
federal government has put in the hands
of local police officers uh
justified proportional measured tools
that will absolutely conform with the
charter of rights and freedoms uh they
are now complaining that we have acting
we will continue to do what is necessary
to keep canadians and their communities
and our economy are safe
for haldeman norfolk canadians are tired
of talking points they want real answers
the prime minister's own words created
fear what are we going to do with these
people these people are taking up space
he said these are the words of a failed
leader who robbed canadians of hope and
of unity and that is why they took to
the streets when will this prime
minister stop doubling down on his
failed leadership and admit that it is
it is his divisive words and mandates
that led to so much turmoil in this
country
[Applause]
believes the vaccine mandates we came
forward within this country saved lives
the vaccine mandates uh for travelers uh
for
federal public servants contributed to
one of the highest vaccination rates in
the world by canadians that has kept
people safer it has allowed our economy
to come roaring back and has allowed us
to get through this
challenging pandemic better than most
unfortunately conservatives are now
supporting illegal blockades that are
harming our economy that's not what
member for calgary knows hill
earlier in question period the prime
minister said that the emergencies act
should not be the quote first or second
thing that should be used to resolve a
crisis situation
what were the first and second things
the prime minister did and how does the
failure of those actions provide legal
justification for the invocation of the
emergencies act
[Music]
mr speaker when we began to see illegal
blockades in place we made sure that the
rcmp uh was there to offer resources to
local police of jurisdiction to work
with the opp uh to ensure that the
support and planning is was there for
the police of local jurisdiction uh to
take action as time went on and uh these
illegal blockades became more and more
dug in we saw that there was a need for
more and more tools until it got to the
point where canadians livelihoods
canadians well-being the residents of
ottawa being severely impacted threats
of violence at border crossings across
the country honorable member for calgary
nose hill the problem with that argument
is that the illegal blockades at the
ambassador bridge and the couts
crossings occurred prior to the
emergencies act being involved without
federal help and the emergency act was
not needed to settle the rail blockades
of 2020 the oka crisis the crisis at
caledonia september 11th the coven 19
pandemic or any other dispute in
canadian history the prime minister has
not provided any legal justification for
the use of the emergencies act a
historic unfettered power grab he needs
to calmly tell canadians why he has
failed and what is different today
the honorable right honorable prime
minister
mr speaker the invocation of the
emergencies act is not something to be
done lightly on that we absolutely agree
that is why not only did we lay out the
rationale and explain to canadians why
we're doing it and how we're doing it
not only why we made sure that the new
powers are circumspect are proportional
or to be used only where they are needed
but we also are about to have uh days of
debate in the house on exactly these
questions so that parliamentarians and
indeed all canadians are able uh to see
that this was necessary
courageous
[Applause]
uh
situations
[Applause]
is
uh
optimistic hopeful vision for public
life isn't a naive dream it could be a
powerful force for change if canadians
are to trust their government their
government needs to trust canadians
those are the words of the prime
minister in 2015.
these people very often misogynistic
racists women haters science deniers the
fringe same prime minister six years
later as he fans the flames of an
unjustified national emergency so mr
speaker when did the prime minister lose
his way when did it happen
[Applause]
mr speaker
conservative party members can stand
with people who wave swastikas they can
stand with people who wave at the
confederate flag we'll choose to stand
with canadians who deserve to be able to
get to their jobs will be able to get
their lives back these illegal protests
need to stop and they will mr speaker
[Applause]
i just want to remind the honorable
members including the honorable right
honourable prime minister
to use words that are not inflammatory
in the house
and that's for both sides
[Applause]
it's been 48 hours that the government
went from doing nothing to a national
emergency 48 hours into using the
measures 48 hours without providing
parliament with the justification so my
question is simple when will the prime
minister admit that he's lost control of
the situation that he's lost control of
his country that he's lost control of
his caucus and that he's lost control of
his leadership
[Applause]
caucus and support for these blockades
the conservative politicians need to
make a choice are they for the blockades
or are they for communities our economy
and regular canadians the member from
provenche pointed out at the emergency
block the illegal blockades he has never
seen such a patriotic display in canada
there's nothing patriotic about hurting
fellow canadians the member from grand
prairie mckenzie claims that the economy
is not being held hostage all the while
hundreds of millions of dollars were
being lost in trade drew to barclays and
the member from sarnia lambton doesn't
believe her constituents need guaranteed
access now to the bluewater bridge mr
speaker we stand with canadians
the honourable member for regina capelle
mr speaker in 2020 when anti-energy
protesters were blocking vital
transportation ships were backed up in
ports and trains were stopped the prime
minister didn't stop them in fact he
actually sent a government delegation to
meet with them but now that the
protester built something that he
disagrees with he uses inflammatory
language hurls personal attacks and
makes a massive power grab we know the
pm finds democracy inconvenient and that
he admires china's dictatorship so will
the prime minister admit that this is
all just a move to crack down on dissent
honorable prime
minister mr speaker i would advise the
honorable member to be careful in that
line of line of questioning before
people actually look into what he and
his fellow party conservative party
members said
i want to remind the honorable members
that shouting names at each other is not
the way this place works no no no no no
no before you start clapping start
looking at your own benches
the right honorable prime minister
please continue mr speaker people across
this country have noticed the difference
uh between the uh words and the rhetoric
of the conservative party of canada in
regards uh to indigenous protests in
regards to black lives matter protests
in regards to marginalized people uh
asking for their rights versus uh the
what we're seeing here of illegal
blockades that are hurting regular
canadians uh and even talked about uh
the potential overthrow of a duly
elected government that is not uh what
is responsible for the conservative
honorable member for regina cappell mr
speaker conservatives denounced the
blockades of vital transportation routes
in 2020 and we have denounced the same
blockades this time mr speaker the only
thing that has changed is the prime
minister's reaction when he agreed with
the anti-energy protesters he let them
continue for weeks and even offered a
settlement this time he grants himself
unprecedented powers to attack those he
disagrees with canadians do not want to
live in a country where the prime
minister gets to personally decide which
protests are legitimate so once again
isn't this all just about cracking down
on dissent
the right honourable prime minister
mr speaker as a government we have
always stood up for the right to
peaceful of protests we have always
stood up for the right to free freedom
of assembly or freedom of expression mr
speaker these illegal blockades are
hurting canadians are hurting their
livelihoods uh and are hurting the
well-being and endangering the
well-being of people in communities
across this country uh but the the
former leader of the conservative party
points out that they have stood against
the blockades unfortunately many members
of his party have stood with these
illegal blockades and even encouraged
them to continue blockading their fellow
citizens
honorable member for burnaby
we're in the midst of a national crisis
and this national crisis has exposed
some real frustrations that canadians
feel canadians that have gotten
vaccinated that have followed the public
health guidelines are looking at a
rigged system where billionaires and
millionaires make out like bandits
increase their wealth where working
families and working-class families are
struggling to get by
so what is the prime minister going to
do to respond to the frustrations of
canadians who can't put a roof over
their head we're having struggles to put
food on the table what is he doing to
respond to that real legitimate
frustration the honorable prime minister
mr speaker every step of the way through
this crisis from the from beginning from
the beginning of the pandemic we've had
canadians backs with unprecedented
supports
for our health system so people could
get tests and vaccines and health
supports so people could get wage
subsidies and rent subsidies to keep
small businesses going and to keep
people in their jobs a direct support
for seniors for youth for working
families uh for mothers these are things
that we've moved forward on to have
canadians backs and we will continue to
be investing in housing
in immigration measures in the measures
that are going to be supporting
canadians into the the honorable member
for burnaby south
side
[Music]
of the system
[Music]
[Music]
and findings
[Music]
mr speaker the canadian environmental
protection act was introduced in the
summit last week for their study and
comment
as a member of the house of commons
standing committee for the environment
and sustainable development i look
forward to reviewing this legislation
when it comes to this place could the
prime minister comment on the importance
of this legislation in helping us to
address the climate crisis as well as
recovering clean lakes rivers and
streams and providing ongoing protection
for our environment great thank you the
right honorable prime minister mr
speaker i'd like to thank the member for
guelph for his important question and
his tireless advocacy on behalf of the
environment this bill is a big step
towards strengthening the protection of
canadians health and the health of our
lakes rivers lands and forests from
harmful crop chemicals and other toxic
pollutants this legislation can help us
all become better stewards of our
environment making canada a better place
for us and for the generations that
follow i encourage all parliamentarians
to work together to pass this bill as
soon as possible
remember for red dear lacombe mr speaker
two-thirds of canadians want to see
covet restrictions and mandates lifted
we have amongst the highest vaccination
rate in the world but canadians are
still living under restrictions that
many other less vaccinated countries
have lifted canadians want a plan for
ending restrictions and they are
incredibly disappointed that the ndp and
the liberals blocked our conservative
motion
asking for one so mr speaker if 32 of
the vote is good enough for the liberals
to form government why is it 90
good enough to lift mandates
mr speaker for two years canadians have
been there for each other and all of us
together we've followed the science
we've made sure that people get
vaccinated we've made sure that people
have access to rapid tests every step of
the way we will be ensuring that we're
doing exactly what's necessary both
to keep people safe from covid but also
to get back to the things we love as
quickly as possible i was pleased to see
this week the lifting of a number of
restrictions around international travel
we're going to continue to monitor
carefully and ensure that we follow the
science as we keep canadians safe
the honourable member for carleton trail
eagle creek thank you mr speaker the
only thing this prime minister has made
sure of is that he has politicized this
pandemic and divided canadians at a time
when we should be working together when
we should be supporting one another his
lack of leadership has divided
stigmatized and traumatized canadians
provincial premiers are leading the way
giving hope confidence and rebuilding
trust in leadership when will this prime
minister follow their lead
honourable prime minister
mr speaker
the 90
vaccination rate in canada shows that
canadians have actually never been more
united the stories we saw throughout
this pandemic of people being there for
their neighbors people there to support
frontline workers people there to
support uh their communities
demonstrates the ability to which
canadians have stepped up to be there
for each other yes there have been
people who've been harassing and
intimidating frontline workers yes there
are people involved in frontline in
illegal blockades but the vast majority
of canadians continue to stand alongside
each other and support each other
mr speaker two-thirds of canadians are
united because they want an end to
mandates and lockdowns but this prime
minister said they're called racist
misogynist a fringe who quote take up
space and he said shouldn't be tolerated
security experts say the emergencies act
as a quote absolutely unprecedented
excessive overreach and half the
provinces oppose it but this pm's
pattern is failure and top-down division
he's gone from name-calling to nukes
isn't this really about the prime
minister taking a sledgehammer to
canadians that he thinks are
unacceptable
the right honorable prime minister
mr speaker i believe the member opposite
misspoke i think it's actually a hundred
percent of canadians who are tired of
this covet pandemic who are tired of
having to uh be restricted of having
tired of having uh to be impacted by
this pandemic around the around the
country and around the globe we all want
to get through it however the way to get
through it
is by following science by keeping each
other safe by being there for each other
the way through this pandemic isn't to
engage in illegal blockades uh that are
harming their fellow canadians
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Applause]
oh
is
he's leaving behind
is
the emergencies act to deal with the
crisis
please
is
mr speaker
[Music]
citizenship
mr speaker i've never seen such shameful
and dishonorable remarks coming from
this prime minister
my great grandfather flew over 30
missions over nazi germany my great
great uncle's body lies at the bottom of
the english channel there are members of
this conservative caucus who are the
descendants of victims of the holocaust
for the prime minister to accuse any
colleague in this house of standing with
the swastika is shameful i'm giving the
prime minister an opportunity i'm
calling on him to unreservedly apologize
for this shameful remark
the right honorable prime minister
mr speaker
canadians deserve their freedoms back mr
speaker these illegal blockades that
have continued to interfere with
people's livelihoods to interfere with
people's uh people's daily lives i have
i have to interrupt the honorable prime
minister so
ask everyone to calm down so we can hear
the answer the right honourable prime
minister
mr speaker
the measures put forward in this
emergencies act are proportional are
responsible and quite frankly uh are
completely folded within the charter of
rights and freedoms the steps that we
are taking are important and measured to
restore order and freedoms to canadians
in this country that is exactly what we
are doing a member of first urgent river
parkland mr speaker the lack of an
apology from that prime minister speaks
volumes i have given this prime minister
an opportunity to retract a shameful
remark where he would accuse any
honorable member of this house to stand
with a swastika as i said before we have
colleagues who are the descendants of
victims of the holocaust i'm giving the
prime minister one more chance will he
apologize to all members of this house
[Applause]
even as the members of the conservative
party are calling to uh to us to take
more action over the past two weeks on
this they continued to stand with and
encourage these illegal blockades mr
speaker canadians are watching carefully
and see exactly where the conservative
politicians who've stood with those
blockades
are standing we will stand on the side
of canadians who deserve their lives
backs who deliver their livelihoods back
member for sturgeon river parkland my
apologies mr speaker i didn't write
these out
but
the fact is i don't know how any member
of the government caucus can stand by
this prime minister when he accuses
honorable members of this house of
standing with a swastika i'm calling on
all members of the liberal caucus to
denounce the prime minister i have given
him two chances to apologize he has
refused to apologize mr prime minister
apologize
once again i want to remind the
honourable members i know this is
getting emotional but place your
questions through the speaker not
directly to each other the right
honourable prime minister
thank you mr speaker these illegal
blockades have been going on in ottawa
for 20 days now
people have been
have been interrupted in their daily
lives have been made to feel fearful
have been made
to
miss shifts at their work in across
southern ontario these are things that
cannot be stood for which is why we're
moving forward with a responsible set of
measures to allow the local police
jurisdiction to do their jobs we
continue to defend freedom of expression
freedom of assembly as long as it's
peaceful and legal mr speaker
[Applause]
she's only interested
is
is
is
[Applause]
is
is
is
[Applause]
foreign
is
is
[Applause]
elections
foreign
and they will continue
mr speaker immigrants from coast to
coast to coast have significantly
contributed to the prosperity of this
country and of my riding of scarborough
agincourt last year we exceeded our goal
of welcoming over 401 000 immigrants
that will make canada their home this
was a historical record that will help
shape canada's growth can the prime
minister update this house on our
government's plan to welcome more
newcomers in the coming years
you're right honorable prime minister mr
speaker immigration is and has always
been essential to canada's success this
pandemic has highlighted the
contributions of newcomers to the
well-being of our communities and across
all sectors of the economy it's why we
tabled our most ambitious immigration
plant levels plan yet this plan will
welcome more newcomers in the next in
the three in the coming year and will
continue to help key sectors of our
economy it'll help staff almost a
million unfilled positions across all
sectors will also help filling in for
the five million canadians set to retire
by 2030. you're here honourable member
for burnaby south
thank you mr speaker
many canadians are raising
serious concerns that the emergency
disease act should not apply to legal
protests we know that there have been
many counter-protesters who are standing
up to the convoy and we've seen some of
those counter protesters arrested by
police instead of the actual convoy so
canadians raise the question what
assurances will the prime minister
provide so that legal protests
are not impacted by the invocation of
the emergencies act
right honorable prime minister speaker
excellent question one we are also very
much
preoccupied with which is why uh in the
measures set forward we've been very
clear to indicate that illegal protests
illegal barricades illegal blockages are
the ones that we're giving extra tools
for the police to respond to of course
we will always stand up for canadians
charter rights we will always stand up
for freedom of peaceful assembly of
freedom of expression that is extremely
important but we also know it is the
police of jurisdiction who need to do
their jobs and not canadians taking
things into their own hands to end these
illegal protests that's what we're
ensuring with this measure
that's all the time we have for
questions